his reputation and on which his
fingerprints are indelibly printed given
that money that given that massive
defeat will he now commit to meaningful
engagement with the Scottish government
and consideration of alternative plans
including remaining in a single market
and the customs union Mr Speaker I make
no apology for supporting the Prime
Minister's deal I believe that it was
the right deal for Scotland and the
United Kingdom and of course we will
engage constructively with a the First
Minister and the Scottish Government but
if we are to do so then they must bring
forward proposals other than stopping
brexit and starting another independence
referendum Shepherd
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. speaker I was going to suggest that
the Secretary of State is still equipped
to take this process forward in Scotland
but he makes the argument for me yeah
given his refusal to engage properly in
discussion about alternatives given the
fact he is so out of step with opinion
in Scotland at every level will he now
do the decent thing and resign step
aside so that someone else can take this
forward mr. speaker that's getting a
little tired I thought the Honourable
gentleman could think of another sound
abate I'm not out of step with opinion
in Scotland people in Scotland do not
want another independence referendum
and they recognize that the SNP has
weaponized brexit in order to try and
deliver such a referendum and in Faust
question number six please mr. speaker
mr. speaker
leaving the Common Fisheries Policy will
allow the UK to take back control of our
waters becoming an independent coastal
state we will negotiate a fairer share
of fishing opportunities to benefit
fishermen in Scotland and across the
whole of the United Kingdom I thank my
right and my friend for the positive
assessment he's just given the prospects
not just for Scotland's fishing industry
prefer whole of the UK from leaving be
used Common Fisheries Policy yet will he
agree those benefits will be lost
if we listen to the arguments of those
who want to separate our union but
reunite Scotland with the European
Union's Common Fisheries Policy indeed
my honourable friend is absolutely right
the SNP are false friends two Scottish
fishermen they want to keep Scotland in
the CFP by staying in the EU and failing
that they want an independent Scotland
to rejoin the CFP throughout the
negotiations this government has shown
that it has put the interests of
Scottish fishermen and those across the
UK at the heart of our approach to
leaving the EU but in Wakefield right
from mr. speaker would no deal not be a
disaster for the fishing industry and it
supports industries and shouldn't weigh
saying no to No Deal now what's a mr.
speaker if that's the honourable
gentleman's view then he should have
voted for the Prime Minister's deal last
night mr. Alistair Carmichael he was the
speaker if the government's commitment
to ending the CFP on the 31st of
December of next year is sincere why
does the government continued to resist
amendments to put that deep on the face
of the fisheries bill I don't think that
my right honourable former colleague
will find that that is an accurate
interpretation of the government's
positions and my colleagues
right on like the Honorable gentleman
for BAMF and buckin has argued strongly
for that case said we will see what
happens when the bill returns at report
stage order questions to the prime
minister
Charlie elphic number one mr. speaker
the Prime Minister q Mr Speaker I am
sure that the whole house will join me
in condemning the appalling attack in
Nairobi and in sending my thoughts and
prayers to all those who have lost loved
ones our High Commissioner has confirmed
one British fatality and we're providing
consular assistance to British nationals
affected by the attack we stand in
solidarity with the government and
people of Kenya and will continue to
offer our support to meet the challenge
to security and stability that is posed
by terrorism in the region mr. speaker
this morning I have meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today
Charlie elphic Thank You mr. speaker may
I join with the prime minister in her
strong condemnation on terror and so you
will know mr. speaker and the premier
sir will know that I first sought
election to this house because I
believed in more jobs lower taxes a
stronger economy the more investment in
the public services on which we all rely
on does she agree that since 2010
Conservative government's have delivered
time and again for the British people
[Applause]
and the biggest threat to that is sat on
the opposition front bench with a leader
whose policies would mean less jobs
higher taxes a weaker economy and less
my honorable friend is absolutely right
what have we seen under the
Conservatives in government we've seen
3.4 million more that's more people
earning an income earning a wage able to
provide for their families we've seen
more children in good and outstanding
schools more money into our national
health service
what would put that in danger a
government led by the right honourable
gentleman more borrowing more taxes more
spending fewer jobs in
Thank You mr. speaker thank you may I
start by correcting the record last
night I suggested this was the largest
government defeat since the 1920s
I would not wish to be accused of
misleading the house because I've since
been informed that is in fact the
largest ever defeat for a government in
the history of our democracy
so mr. speaker shortly after the Prime
Minister made her point of order last
night her spokesperson suggested the
government had ruled out any form of
customs union with the European Union as
part of her reaching out exercise can
the Prime Minister confirm that's the
case gentlemen that the exercise that I
indicated last night is as I said about
listening to the views of the house
about wanting to understand the views of
parliamentarians so that we can identify
what could command the support of this
house and deliver on the referendum and
what the government wants to do is first
of all to ensure that we deliver on the
result of the referendum that's leaving
the European Union and we want to do it
in a way that ensures we respect the
votes of those who voted to leave in
that referendum that means ending free
movement it means getting a fairer deal
for farmers and fishermen it means it
means opening up new opportunities to
trade with the rest of the world and it
means keeping good ties with our
neighbors in Europe my question was
about the customs union the Prime
Minister seems to be in denial about
that just as much as she's in denial
about the decision made by the house
last night I understand the business
secretary told business leaders on a
conference call last night we can't have
no deal for all the reasons you've set
out can the Prime Minister now reassure
the house businesses and the country and
confirm that is indeed the government's
position that we can't have no deal the
business sector is making that he has
made previously is that if you don't
want to have no deal you have to ensure
that you have a deal now I will give
this
I will give this - I will I will say
this - the right honourable gentleman
there are actually two ways of avoiding
no deal the first is to agree a deal and
the second would be to revoke article 50
now that would mean staying in the
European Union to respect the result of
the referendum and that is and that is
something that this government will not
do on a customs union hasn't answered on
on No Deal and continue to spend 4.2
billion of public money on a No Deal
scenario can't she understand yesterday
the House rejected deal she needs to
come up with something different than
that but Mr Speaker it's not just on
brexit that this government is failing
formally and working people are living
in poverty half a million more children
in poverty compared to 2010 the
Roundtree foundation confirms in work
poverty is rising faster than the
overall employment rate with poverty
rising can the Prime Minister tell us
when we can expect it to fall for the
time she remains in office gentlemen
what is happening we now see 1 million
fewer people in absolute poverty
that is a record-low we see 300,000
fewer children in absolute poverty that
is a record low
we see a record low in the number of
children living in worthless households
and income inequality income inequality
lower than at any point under the last
Labour government conservatives
delivering for the people of this
country what would we see from the
neighbor party 1000 billion pounds more
in borrowing and taxes the equivalent of
thirty five thousand pounds for every
household in this country that's labour
failing to deliver for working people
because working people always pay the
price of the labour party
[Music]
in denial on a customs union in denial
on no deal in denial on the amount of
money being spent preparing for No Deal
in denial on last night's results and
even the UN Rapporteur on poverty says
the government is well
mr. speaker mr. speaker it's very it's
very telling very telling indeed that as
soon as I mention the report of the UN
reporter who said the government was in
a state of denial about poverty in
Britain Tory MP start jeering tell that
to people queuing up at food banks the
government - mr. speaker has failed on
children's education can the Prime
Minister tell us what is her greatest
failure is it that education funding has
been cut by seven billion per pupil
funding fallen by 8 percent sixth-form
funding cut by 1/5 or that the adult
skills budget has been slashed by forty
five percent which is it Prime Minister
hundreds of free schools are reformed
curriculum 1.9 million more children in
good or outstanding schools narrowing
the achievement gap for disadvantaged
children this is a government that is
delivering the education that our
children need for their future but I say
to the right honourable gentleman he
says he talks about being in denial the
only person in denial in this chamber is
him because he is consistently
consistently failed to set out what his
policy on brexit is I said to him last
week I said to him last week that he
might do with a lip-reader
I think when it comes to his brexit
policy the rest of us need a mind-reader
Gorman mr. speaker the Prime Minister is
very well aware that we wanted to be a
customs union with the EU she seems to
be in denial about that but one of the
problems she has on her denial is the
flagrant disregard for this fact and
statistics and the statistics authority
has written to the Department of
Education four times to express their
concern about the use of dodgy figures
by her ministers when police officers
told that then Home Secretary not to
make more cuts to police that Home
Secretary accused them of crying wolf
with 21,000 fewer police officers and
rising crime across the country does the
Prime Minister accept that the then Home
Secretary got it wrong of course as we
look at what is happening particularly
at what is happening on live crime and
serious violence we recognise the need
to take action that's why we've
introduced the offensive weapons bill
and it's why my right honourable friend
the Home Secretary has introduced the
serious violence strategy it's also we
are also making nearly 1 billion pounds
more available to priests forces over
the next year but I also say to the
right honourable gentleman yet again in
all of these questions about public
services he only ever talks about the
money that's going in what matters what
matters with the police is the powers
that we give them as well and what was
it what was it when we came to the issue
of knife crime when we came to the issue
of knife crime when he came to the issue
of taking more action at criminals who
were involved in knife crime when we
said that if somebody was caught on the
streets for a second time for a nice
crime they should be sent to prison
what did the right honourable gentleman
do he voted against
doesn't support our police he doesn't
support our security increased the
number of police on our streets it was a
Labour government that brought in safer
neighborhoods it was a Labour government
that properly funded the police force
it's the Tories that have cut it ask
anyone on any Street around this country
do they feel safer now than they did
eight years ago I think we all know what
the answer would be it was that Home
Secretary that not only attacked the
police with that but also created the
hostile environment and the Windrush
scandal she promised to tackle burning
in Justices she's made them worse as
Windrush showed more homelessness more
children in poverty more older people
without care longer waits at A&E fewer
nurses rising crime less safe streets
cuts the children's education this
government has failed our country it
cannot govern cannot command the support
of most people facing the most important
issue at the moment which is brexit they
failed again and lost the vote last
night isn't it the case Mr Speaker that
with every other previous Prime Minister
faced with a scale of defeat last night
they would have resigned and the country
would be able to choose the government
that they want
[Music]
the right honourable gentleman in that
for peroration talked about the
importance of the issue of brexit that
is facing this country later today we
will have the we're going to have the
no-confidence debate he has been calling
for weeks for a general election in this
country and yet on sunday when he was
asked in a general election would he
campaign to leave the European Union he
refused to answer not once not twice not
three times but five times he refused to
answer so on what he himself describes
as the key issue facing this country he
has no answer
the leader of the Opposition the leader
of the Opposition has let anti-semitism
run riot in his
he would abandon our allies weaken our
security and wreck our economy and we
will never let that happen
[Applause]
[Music]
the Prime Minister we aware of the
serious minerals project in my
constituency that is already employing
around a thousand people and he's set to
boost British exports by two billion
pounds from her visits to China where
she met the company's customers Sheila
how important this Polihale like
fertilizer product can be around the
world the company is currently seeking a
treasury guarantee to complete its
financing does the Prime Minister agree
with me that this is precisely the sort
of project the government should be
supporting to show our commitment to the
northern powerhouse and the industrial
strategy can I say to my right
honourable friend I'd like to thank you
for raising this issue because I was
particularly pleased to meet the CEO CEO
of serious during my trip to China and
talk to them about the work that they're
doing and it's years as he says exactly
projects like this that drive investment
and exports in the north but of what the
northern powerhouse is all about now in
relation to the particular discussions
my right honourable friend mentioned I'm
sure he'll understand these are
commercially sensitive so it will be
inappropriate for me to comment on the
specific discussions but this as I say
is exactly the sort of project that is
what the northern powerhouse is all
about in driving investment driving
experts good for the north in Blackford
Thank You mr. speaker can I associate
myself with the remarks of the prime
minister than the atrocity in Kenya and
of course our solidarity with the people
there
mr. speaker yesterday the Attorney
General said that any new deal would be
much the same as the one already on the
table
we know that the European Union won't
renegotiate
if the Prime Minister survives today to
bring forward her plan be whoa she
concede that Plan B would basically be a
redressing of planning in my answers to
the leader of the Opposition what we
want to do following the defeat that
that we had in this house last night is
listen to parliamentarians and find out
the point at which what is it that would
secure the support of this house that is
the question that we will be asking but
that is against the background of
ensuring that we deliver on the
referendum result that we leave the
European Union and we recognize what
people were voting for when they voted
in that referendum result an end to free
movement ensuring that we could have
trade negotiator have our own trade
policy with the rest of the world be
fair as well farmers fairer to our
fishermen but maintain that good
relationship with our neighbors in the
EU the in black bird I'm afraid mr.
speaker that simply didn't address the
question the EU won't renegotiate the
prime minister has no answer she has
failed what an omni shambles from this
government suffering a historic and a
humiliating defeat the worst for any
Yuki government Westminster is in chaos
in Scotland in 80 mr. speaker Scotland
voted overwhelmingly to remain and we
move north among our country to be
dragged out to the UNEP Union or brought
down by her story government the Prime
Minister you that this deal was dead
since checker she knew it was dead when
she moved the meaningful vote and she
knows as we all know last night was the
last straw
the Prime Minister must now seek the
confidence of the people not simply the
confidence of this house the only way
forward is to extend article 50 and ask
the people of Scotland and of the United
Kingdom whether they want the Prime
Minister's deal or whether they want to
remain in the European Union mr. speaker
the Prime Minister might now must
legislate 40 people's vote as he knows I
as I thought and as I have said before
this house legislated for a people's
vote it legislated for people's vote
that was held in 2016 and that vote that
votes determined that the United Kingdom
should leave the European Union he talks
about our country our country is the
whole of the United Kingdom
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland and
it is for the whole of the United
Kingdom that we will be looking for a
solution that secures the support of
this house and ensures that this
Parliament delivers on the vote of the
people thank you thank you mr. speaker
on behalf of all the members of the all
party group on Kenya which I chair on
behalf of my honourable friend the
member for Derbyshire the Prime
Minister's trade envoy to Kenya can we
express our sincere condolences and
sympathy to the President and people of
Kenya and encourage them in their fight
against this terrorism my right
honourable friend has rightly committed
very very substantial amounts of extra
money to the NHS her and her government
and the plan produced last week is very
encouraging but can she also look at the
difference between the money given to
the highest CCGs and the lowest CCGs per
head we're not wanting to see amounts
come down but we do want to see a fairer
formula to allocate money for those CCGs
receiving the lowest amount thank my
honourable friend for the remarks that
he made from his position as chairman if
your party
parliamentary group understand it on
Kenya I was pleased when I visited Kenya
last August to meet with some of those
who are working to fight terrorism doing
in very important work to bring
stability and security to people in that
region and very important that is to
first of all thank my honorable friend
for highlighting the long-term plan that
we've set out for the National Health
Service that the resources allocated to
CCGs reflect the needs of the population
and that includes levels of deprivation
and the ODE age profile of the
population and changes have been made to
the allocations for 2019-20
increasing the fair share allocations
for Staffordshire CCGs which I'm sure my
honourable friend is particularly
interested in and they will see a higher
level of growth in their actual budgets
over the next five years and that
difference will ensure that overtime
funding across the Staffordshire and
stoke-on-trent CCGs will become fairer
so that biggest cash boost in the NHS is
history is in a
us to do that and I think that I hope
that we'll be addressing the issue that
my girlfriend has raised because I'll
defeat yesterday was historic and
Titanic everything has changed and she
has to change - yesterday thousands of
people to say that on Parliament Square
to demand their say nobody was taken to
the streets demanding a Norway or a
Canada option she when she came to power
she promised that she would give people
more power over their lives if she is
not going to give people power to have a
say over this deal then what is the
point of that promise in the first place
honourable gentleman that he cannot
ignore the fact but in the 2016
referendum that in 2016 referendum the
people of this country voted to leave
the European Union and I believe that it
is a duty not just of government but of
Parliament to ensure that we deliver on
that we will be we will be speaking to
parliamentarians in my own party the DUP
across the house about finding a way
that secures the support of the house
for the way forward but I say to the
honourable gentleman once again a vote
was taken in 2016 and I believe it is
incumbent on this Parliament to deliver
on that vote
Thank You mr. speaker my right
honourable friend will remember from her
visits to Copeland just how capable our
nuclear community is and how proud we
are of that heritage what she said a
meeting with me and a small delegation
of Cumbrian nuclear workers to
understand how important mu site is to
Copeland and to also bear in mind the
solutions that the center of excellence
can bring to that challenge my friend
when I have visited Copeland it's been
very clear to me not only the expertise
and skills that in the nuclear industry
that are there with the population but
also the importance of the nuclear
industry as regard for Moorside site it
is it will revert the nuclear
decommissioning Authority and we are
considering options for its future it
the site does remain eligible for new
nuclear new build and we are committed
to seeing new nuclear as part of our
future energy mix but can I say to my
honourable friend that I think it might
be helpful if the relevant minister from
the business department were to meet
with her and that group to be able to
explore this issue further Seema
Malhotra mr. speaker last night in this
house after the biggest government
defeat in history the prime minister
said the government will approach
meetings with parliamentarians in a
constructive spirit but it appears that
cross party talks means inviting people
in to tell them why her deal is best or
to see if they've got any ideas on how
to get her deal through apparently now
number Ten's resistance to a customs
union with the european union after
breaks it was a principal and not a
redline so which is it and if she is
genuinely seeking to work with
Parliament and hear the will of this
house is she prepared to change any of
her red lines and work to bring
Parliament and the country together on
how we move forward
as I said in the house last night I will
be talking to parliamentarians on in my
own party in the DUP in other parties
across this house and will be and will
be ensuring and will be looking to see
what it is that can secure the support
of this house but again I say if the
Honourable lady as I've said to her
honorable and right honourable friends
that what this house must always have in
mind is the importance of delivering on
the vote of the people to leave the
European Union
Prime Minister agree with me that if we
fail to deliver on credit the public
perception of politicians in this
country will be at an all-time low
[Applause]
absolutely agree with my honourable
friend and this and this is so important
I believe that if we fail to deliver on
what the British people instructed us to
do in the vote of the referendum that
the the views of the British people of
this house of parliament and of
politicians will be at an all-time low
because they will have lost they will
have lost faith in politicians across
the whole of this
we need to deliver brexit for the
British people dr. Roberta Blackman
Woods the Prime Minister may have
created a brighter brexit crisis but
other crises are unfolding too chronic
health conditions and obesity in the
northeast are the highest of any English
region and people in Durham over 65 can
only expect eight years of healthy
living compared to 14 in windsor and
maidenhead so why on earth is the Prime
Minister planning to cut Durham's public
health budget by a massive forty percent
that will not only worsen health
outcomes of my constituents it will
ultimately cost the NHS more and further
widen health inequalities in terms of
Public Health and funding that will be
looked at in the spending review but if
she assumes that the only action that is
taken in relation to obesity and other
conditions in terms of prevention is
through public health that is not the
case if she looks at the known HS
long-term plan that has been announced
and looked a funded of course by the
biggest cash boost in the NHS East
history given by this government what
she will see is an emphasis on
prevention and on emphasis on ensuring
that people are able to lead healthier
independent lives for longer mr. Kenneth
Clarke
Mr Speaker I sat through many hours on
every day but one of the recent debates
and I did listen very carefully to the
extraordinary range of views that was
expressed on all sides throughout it and
it did seem to me that the only clear
majorities in this house on a
cross-party basis are firstly against
leaving with No Deal
a gay in favor of extending article 52
give us time to sort out what it is we
now propose to do
and in favor of a customs union some
[Applause]
sufficient regulatory alignment to keep
all our borders between the United
Kingdom and the European Union open
after we leave will the Prime Minister
not just as I have had to accept that
the majority in this house is committed
to the UK leaving the European Union
that she must accept that she must now
modify her red lines which she created
for herself at Lancaster House and find
a cross-party majority which will be
along the lines that I have indicated my
right honourable friend started off by
saying there were a considerable numbers
a considerable number of views across
this house it is precisely because of
that that we will be undertaking the
discussions with members with
parliamentarians that I indicated what
happened last night that I indicated
would happen last night he talks about
the possible extension of article 50 of
course article 50 cannot be extended by
the UK it has to be extended in in
consultation in agreement with the
European Union the government's policy
the government's policy is that we're
leaving the European Union on the 29th
of March but the EU would only extend
article 50 if actually it was clear
there was a plan that was moving towards
an agreed deal
that is the crucial element of ensuring
we deliver on brexit is being able to
get the agreement of this house to the
deal that will deliver on the referendum
result leave the European Union and
recognize what they behind that vote
when people voted to leave Thank You mr.
speaker
in my constituency in the villages of
easing Tenkaichi hoardin and black hole
that there are quarry rows standing
derelicts characterized by low demand
high void rates many are not fit for
human habitation the neglected by
absentee landlords a magnet violently
social behavior and crime so will the
Prime Minister commit to provide the
funding required the housing master plan
developed by Durham County Council to
fix these issues and if she can't do
that which she please get out of the way
and call a general election let us have
a lever
[Applause]
the can I say to the Honourable
gentleman I haven't seen the housing
master plan that he has that he has
referred to but of course it is this
government it is this government that
has put more money into affordable homes
that has put more money into ensuring
that we're seeing more homes being built
and that is and that has lifted lifted
the cap on local councils so that local
councils are also able to build more
homes and the homes that people want
Traci crouch next month I buy three
neighboring colleagues for Maidstone
humberto morning fashion weekend will
host our second apprenticeship fair
connecting nearly 40 leading
organizations with more than 700 pupils
from 22 schools does the Prime Minister
breed me the apprenticeships offer a
viable alternative to full-time higher
education while creating a skilled
workforce that benefits business - first
of all commend my honourable friend for
the work that she's doing in her
constituency through the jobs fairs and
can I absolutely agree with her I think
it is very important that young people
are able to see that there are different
routes for them for their futures
different routes into the workplace and
apprenticeships is an important route
for some young people all the
apprentices I meet say the best thing
they have done is taken up an
apprenticeship and that was right for
them we want every young person to be
able to take the route through be it
higher education further education and
apprenticeship the route that is right
for them yes Ben Qureshi in the 16th and
17th 1.2 million timbrel skills they're
prescribed to women including three of
my constituents
each dose it was equivalent to 40 oral
contraceptives thousands of babies were
born with deformities a recent MHRA
review is widely criticized for being a
white horse
now professor Karl Hannigan at Oxford
University has published a review of the
scientific data that clearly showed that
Primrose did cause deformities will the
problem is to ensure that any response
to this review does not involve the MHRA
and we have no faith in them obviously
to the young lady this is an important
issue it's been raised by a number of
members from across the house and our
priority always is on safety of patients
and members and ministers are aware of
the new study that has come out we have
a commitment to review any new evidence
in this area and we do that but we do it
by could with consulting independent
scientific experts and barrenness kumble
it is leading the independent medicines
and medical devices safety review that's
expected to examine what happened in the
case of prima dose and will determine
what further action is needed but can I
reassure the Honourable lady that we
will listen very carefully to any
recommendations that come out of the
review and of course that study will be
looked at very carefully to see what
comes what has come out of that study
dr. Philip Lee speaker does my right
honourable friend particularly since
last night
recognize that in these complex
circumstances that her role as Prime
Minister now is to create the political
environment in which solutions to the
brexit conundrum can be found and not to
continue with a plan expecting a
different outcome and that she also
accept then that if she cannot get what
she wants that she will need to change
her mind in order to secure public
confidence as I've pointed out today and
as I said last night it is precisely
because we recognize that we need to
understand while the better where it is
that what it is that can command the
support of this house thinking
cure the poise pointed us we will be
looking and we will be talking to
parliamentarians across the house that
includes parliamentarians includes my
colleagues honorable and right
honourable friends includes the
Democratic Unionist Party and
parliamentarians across Arthur as is
because as my right honourable and
learned friend the member for rush cliff
said there is quite a variety of views
across this house about what is right
mr. speaker so the deal was defeated
last night is a product of our orden
lines so which of those red lines is she
willing to give up in order to get the
compromise she seeks we will be as I
said last night we will be approaching
these talks these discussions in a
constructive spirit but underlying what
we will be doing is the need to ensure
that we deliver on the referendum result
and we deliver brexit
Ramon's ish day and you mr.speaker very
much welcome the recent statement by the
Foreign Office Britain must do more to
support persecuted Christians in light
of that won't the government now review
its position on the Asha Beebe case and
offer her Asylum in the UK so she can
choose which safe destination she wanted
to go to and not the UK asking a third
country to take her in which would mean
shifting our moral responsibility to
another country and that can't be right
can i I hope reassure my honourable
friend by saying that as I've said
previously our primary concern is for
the safety and well-being of Ostia baby
and her family and obviously the UK's
High Commission rings in Islamabad is
keeping me in the government up to date
with developments we have been in
contact with international partners
about our shared desire to see a swift
and positive resolution in this case and
a number of countries are in discussions
about a possible alternative destination
for a CFPB once the legal process is
complete I'm not going to comment on the
details of that because this is we do
not want to compromise
Accio BB's long-term safety on on the
timing I think the foreign minister from
Pakistan has confirmed she'll remain on
to the protection of the Pakistan
government until a legal process has
concluded and the Prime Minister of
Pakistan has supported the Supreme Court
and promised to uphold the rule of law
what matters is ensuring that we are
providing for the safety and well-being
of ASEA Bibi and her family Rani
Campbell mr. speaker
the Joseph Rowntree Foundation has said
in a recent survey the four million in
work workers are living in poverty is
another Domon report of nine years of
this Tory government and will just stop
being so hard and fast and college our
election here
I say to the honorable gentleman I I
referred earlier to the figures of
people in absolute poverty which are at
a record low under this government but
he talks about people who are in word
what this government has taken a number
of steps a number of steps to help those
people who are in work we have been
cutting we cut taxes for 32 million
people with increased national living
wage we've helped people by freezing
fuel duty and what happened what
happened in a number of the measures
that we have taken to give to give
financial help to people who are just
about managing to people the sort of
people he's talking about
unfortunately in so many cases the
Labour Party opposed those measures
Martin Vickers speaker in an article I
posted on my website in November I put I
concluded by saying hopefully we will
eventually come to a position that both
sides who support the agreement and
those like me who oppose it can coalesce
I believe this could happen over coming
weeks though there may be more drama
before we reach that point mr. speaker I
think we've all had our fair share of
drama but would my right honourable
friend agree agree with me that it's not
both sides meaning remain and leave whom
others coalesce around an agreement it
is the European Union and can I urge her
to continue negotiations with Europe in
in the hope of them showing some
flexibility
can I thank my own boyfriend for
pointing out a very what is very obvious
point but actually has been not been
raised by those who've been talking
about the sort of discussions we will
have across this Parliament which is I
want to see what will secure the support
of the house but of course we do have to
ensure that that can secure the support
of the European Union because this is a
treaty an agreement between two parties
and as I said last night once we have
those ideas from the from the house I
will of course take those to the
European Union David Crosby in March
2010 Greater Manchester Police had eight
thousand one hundred and forty-eight
police officers and the Chief Constable
wanted ten thousand by June 2018 we had
six thousand one hundred and ninety-nine
and the numbers are still going down
incidents of crime arising right across
Bolton and is it any wonder and more
importantly mr. speaker
is it acceptable that the police are
failing to attend violent attacks and
systematic drug-dealing location
indicated earlier we have as a
government made more money available to
police forces next year nearly a billion
pounds extra will be available to to
police horses but it isn't just of
course about the money that's available
to police forces it is about the power
that the police have and its that is why
we have been introducing the offensive
weapons bill it's why we continually
take action to make sure the police have
the power they need to keep us safe
Nicky Morgan thank you very much indeed
mr. speaker to her point of order last
night and the questions are so far at
this question time does my right
boyfriend agree that we all need to
maintain maximum flexibility if we are
to build a consensus around brexit in
this house
as I said last night we will approach
the discussions we will have with
honorable members and right honourable
members across this house with in a
constructive spirit the the one and as I
said earlier what we do need to retain
though as we're looking at those
discussions to find what will secure the
support of the house is to remember that
what we are doing is finding a way to
deliver brexit and deliver on the vote
of the British people what do you play
Minister but it's notable that I had a
question David Cameron's final PM - last
night after the play ministers crushing
defeat she said EU citizens who have
made their home here deserve clarity on
these questions as soon as possible mr.
speaker the clarity is in the plamen
sisters own hands so well she knows sure
leadership proves that she values EU
nationals scrap the settled the settled
status fee and give a guarantee to all
the EU nationals that their future and
the UK is secured with all agreement
that was negotiated with the European
Union set out the ways in which EU
citizens rights would be guaranteed here
in the United Kingdom and reciprocal
rights for UK citizens in the European
Union would be guaranteed now the vote
last night rejected that package of the
withdrawal agreement and the and the
political declaration we have said as a
government and made it clear that in a
no deal situation we will also guarantee
the rights of EU citizens who are living
here and we stand by that
Julian Keegan
no country is ever left the EU using
article 50 so I do not underestimate the
challenge but back in the real world
businesses up and down the country with
the possible exception of Wetherspoons
are extremely disappointed with the last
night's vote and short-term investment
decisions are still on hold or going
against the UK agree that protecting
just-in-time supply chains on which my
constituents jobs depend must be at the
heart of any solution tomorrow friend
that she has raised a very important
point because of course what the deal we
put to Parliament last night one of the
things it did do was to protect those
just in time
supply chain models and our position on
their importance past not changed today
as we look ahead to today's vote backing
the government today will enable us to
find a way forward on brexit and on the
issues as she says that matter at home
and ensure that this country has the
government it needs to take its forward
it take it forward to deliver on the
referendum and as she says ensure that
we are protecting the jobs not just of
her constituents but jobs around the
whole of this country gulliver nuclear
power station is a 20 billion pound UK
Japan trade deal of vital importance to
North Wales to Northwest England and to
UK energy policy as a whole did the
Prime Minister discuss its difficulties
with the Prime Minister of Japan last
week and if not why not we have been we
have been working with itachi we have
been working with the government of
Japan and yes I did raise the issue of
the wilfer a site with the Prime
Minister of Japan last week of course
the company involved will be making a
commercial decision in relation to this
matter the government has been in
discussion with them for some time has
been providing support we do want to see
new nuclear as part of our energy mix in
the future we also have to make sure
that the cost of any energy that is
provided by nuclear is at a reasonable
level for the consumer Kirstin hair
I recently welcomed the news from the
Secretary of State for detains in his
ministerial team that in five four five
commando would remain RM Condor in my
constituency and Zulu company parts of
the four or five commando group recently
took part in specialist chemical
training which will ensure they are
ready to respond first to any chemical
or biological attacks such as the one
that we had in Salisbury earlier it last
year can the Prime Minister join with me
in congratulating the Royal Marines at
four or five commanders all the men and
women that work at the peace for the
tireless work that they do to keep our
country safe well can I can I say to my
honourable friend I'd like to thank her
for raising this issue I know she has
raised this in her Westminster Hall
debate because it's of importance to her
but it's also important to many other
members around this house and I would
like to pay tribute to all the Royal
Marines past and present who served in
RM Condor and I'm pleased to say that we
do plan for four or five commando to
remain based at RM Condor barracks in
Angus will ensure they continue to have
the required facilities for them to live
work and train in Angus and I'm
delighted in joining my honourable
friend in congratulating Zulu company
for their hard work in keeping us safe
you cable can I first of all welcome the
Prime Minister's offer of cross party
talks and she will remember as well
former colleagues that my party has a
record of working with others in the
national interest
[Applause]
when I say to whether she shovels even
bother lifting the telephone to
opposition parties unless she's willing
to rule out categorically a new due
brexit unless she's willing to enter
into a constructive conversation about a
people's vulnerable gentleman as I said
earlier of course there are two ways of
avoiding a No Deal one is to have a deal
and one is to stay in the European Union
we will not be staying in the European
Union but I look forward to having I'm
always I'm always happy to have
constructive discussions with party
leaders who want to put the national
interest first sadly from everything
I've heard not every party leader wants
to do that dr. Sarah Wallace they're
driving off a cliff never ends well
particularly if it results in a crash
and burn brexit with No Deal in just 72
days time but there's another way that
we can avoid this and that is to be
realistic in extending article 50 to
allow us to put a realistic negotiated
brexit direc to the British people to
ask if it has their consent when also to
include an option to remain with the
excellent deal we already have
so she will not be surprised to hear
because I've said it this are in Prime
Minister's Questions today I believe we
should deliver on the vote of the
referendum in 2016 that we should be
delivering brexit as I've indicated
earlier to her the she and others have
talked about extending article 50 the
European Union would only extend article
50 in the circumstances in which it was
going to be possible to come to an
agreement on a deal the talks that we
will be having the discussions I'll be
having with parliamentarians across this
house will be aimed at ensuring that we
can find a way to secure a deal that
will get the support of this house
point of order Hugh Merriman speaker
thank you very much thank you for your
clarity with regard to the behavior of
taking photos in this place it was put
to me this morning by my local BBC that
MPs in this place didn't quite get the
seriousness that the country is feeling
when they behave in such a frivolous
manner I take it one stage further we
set rules and laws in this place and
expect people to abide by them but we
can't seem to do that ourselves not a
great look Kai therefore asked you sir
not so much a reminder of rules that we
already know are in place but what the
sanctions will be for those who are
broken and if there are no sanctions and
to a certain extent sir can I ask that
we maybe reflect the position and change
it to a position where it's currently
being floated I thank the Honourable
gentleman for his point of order
and his courtesy in warning me of his
intention to raise it I take seriously
these breaches of privacy and that is
what they are they are breaches of
privacy by one colleague against others
which is why I made my statement earlier
today I do not expect to have to apply
or to have to ask the house to apply
sanctions on colleagues for breaches of
this sort but as a supporter of
England's finest football club the
Honourable gentleman will know that the
referee has several weapons in his
arsenal before resorting to yellow or
red cards and he can be assured that the
chair keeps a beady eye on offenders
thank you
I all come to the honourable gentlemen
point of order and a Supre mr. speaker
and a member of my staff was abused this
morning as he sought to come to work
there were no police officers outside
the embankment entrance to PCH it wasn't
just a random
of abuse and he was called spineless see
UNT I will not use that word in any
circumstances he is he and no other
member of staff there is no excuse for
them to be abused in this way some of us
have broad shoulders and you know I'm
not going to make the fuss about that we
all know what happened last week and I'm
grateful that the police are finally
doing something about it but it can't be
right that people are standing outside
this place this man who abused my member
staff had been spoken to on three
occasions this morning by police
officers they then had left their post
to go somewhere else
mr. speak I'm grateful to the police who
keep us safe and you know the sort of
conversations I and many others have had
with them and I don't doubt with their
job and make sure that our staff have
exactly the same rights as any other
worker in any other business trade or
profession it will we will have a
situation where our members of staff
will simply no longer work for us mr.
speaker what more can we do let me say
the right honourable lady that I was
shocked to hear of that incident and I
concur entirely with everything that she
has said to the chamber today as